[Musica]
viva di chiudere gli occhi voglio
accompagnarvi in un viaggio
fate un bel respiro
buttate fuori l'aria
e pensate a quel momento particolare con
il vostro partner in cui avete raggiunto
all'intimità più completa e coinvolgente
sì sto parlando proprio di fare l'amore
e ora pensate e cercate di ricordare per
piacere immenso che avete provato
quell'estasi completa che fonde l'anima
il corpo e che ha qualcosa di chimico a
che fare con qualcosa di primordiale e
che vi ha fatto venire le lacrime per il
piacere che avete provato tanto da
volerlo provare per tutta la vita e anzi
a sentire quasi il desiderio anche
adesso che ve lo sto facendo per
valutare
e adesso aprite gli occhi
e cancellate tutto e pensate
esclusivamente alla totale a nei doni a
anedonia è un termine che in medicina in
psichiatria in particolare vuol dire
incapacità di provare piacere per quelle
cose che normalmente dovrebbero dare
piacere come il cibo o come appunto fare
l'amore
io sono un medico e mi occupo di
infertilità che preferisco chiamare
fertilità differente e questo è quello
che arrivano a provare le coppie che
ripongono in quel coito e in quelli
intercorso sessuale esclusivamente il
desiderio di concepire
non mi scorderò mai le parole di una
paziente che in un momento di totale
confidenza mi disse dottoressa quando ho
finito di fare l'amore con mio marito
sento contemporaneamente il seme che
esce da mia genitali e le lacrime che
escono dai miei occhi perché so che sarà
l'ennesimo fallimento lacrime molto
diverse da quello che pensavamo prima
diversamente fertili questo è il termine
che ha utilizzato nel mio pretesto that
talk
l'avevo pensato per distruggere il muro
della vergogna di queste coppie e adesso
quando loro vengono da me e mi dicono
dottoressa siamo diversamente fertili
capisco che quel ted ha fatto il suo
dovere e ha diffuso un messaggio che
valeva la pena di diffondere ma capisco
anche il percorso che hanno dovuto fare
queste coppie per arrivare da me quello
che hanno dovuto leggere sentire
guardate il coraggio che hanno trovato
per denudarsi ed esporre le proprie
fragilità
adesso alzi la mano chi di voi è entrato
mai in contatto con la fertilità
differente vale a dire che ha avuto
qualche esperienza ha conosciuto persone
un fratello una sorella un amico un
cugino che non sa non è riuscita ad
avere figli
ecco tante mani alzate quasi tutte lo
sapete questo perché perché la fertilità
differente colpisce il 30 per cento
delle persone italiane per farvi capire
immaginatevi di essere ad un tavolo e
con dieci persone tre di queste hanno
avuto hanno o avranno problemi di
fertilità
una volta faceva un aperitivo con degli
amici e uno mi ha detto lo sai che mi è
successo il mio migliore amico mi ha
confessato che non riesce ad avere figli
con la propria moglie dopo tanti anni ed
io non ho saputo che dire mi sono
sentito addirittura in imbarazzo
l'imbarazzo
adesso vi faccio fare un altro
esperimento alzi la mano chi a
differenza del mio amico ha saputo dare
la risposta giusta
dare il giusto consiglio fare la giusta
domanda fatemi vedere quanti di voi
nessuno nessuno
che strano la fertilità differente
colpisce il 30 per cento delle persone
italiane e non ci insegnano come
comportarci con i nostri cari che
soffrono di questo sappiamo come
comportarci con i malati oncologici ci
informiamo leggiamo ci fanno dei corsi
con i malati di alzheimer il parkinson e
non sappiamo come comportarci con queste
persone
e allora finiamo per fare le domande
maledette perché non avete figli
guarda che poi più va avanti il tempo
più e faticosa per i figli e vi piace
viaggiare e state sempre in giro non
volete perdere la vostra libertà non
pensando che loro ripongono in quel
viaggio l'unica speranza di con serenità
riuscire ad avere un figlio
spontaneamente
e sapete a cosa sottoponiamo queste
persone questi nostri cari
all'umiliazione
nella mia esperienza di medico ho visto
che le reazioni all'umiliazione che
deriva da queste domande ma anche da
quando io gli dico che non potranno
concepire da soli e avranno bisogno del
mio aiuto
le reazioni sono fondamentalmente 33
cliché ai quali dobbiamo imparare la
controreazione
e poi vi sono il primo è l'aggressività
allora di fronte all'aggressività se sei
un medico che andrebbe di dominarla
dall'alto della tua professionalità il
medico sono io
se sei un nome dico chi verrebbe da dire
o con la stessa aggressività oppure
voltare le spalle e non dargli più retta
invece no dovete reagire con tanta più
dolcezza quanto più forte è
l'aggressività io faccio questo quando
le mie coppie mi aggrediscono ti dico lo
so che stai soffrendo ma adesso è avuto
il coraggio di dirmelo lascia questo
peso a me nun tene occupare più vai a
casa
recuperate la vostra sessualità che
l'avete persa sicuramente ea questo
provo a risolvere questo provo a
risolverlo io
e voi come non medici fate un sorriso
fate vedere che avete capito
accarezzato un braccio stringete un
abbraccio e vedrete che
quell'aggressività si trasformerà prima
impianto e poi in serenità e voi avrete
fatto per quella persona del bene
avrebbe fatto una cosa buona
seconda reazione la diffidenza
la diffidenza a volte la vedo nei loro
occhi quando si siedono e mi guardano
dico per dire ma questa ci capirà
qualcosa di fertilità differente
oppure alla domanda maledetta ma questa
persona che mi fa questa domanda lo sa
che esiste il problema dell'infertilità
lo conosce che esiste in italia questo
problema e nel mondo come dovete reagire
a questo
competenza e conoscenza la competenza la
usa il medico questo percorso io lo
conosco ma ho fatto tantissime volte con
altre coppie le accompagnati
questo è il tuo
queste sono le tue percentuali di
successo e anche queste sono le due
percentuali di insuccesso se sei un nome
dico la conoscenza
guarda che il tuo problema ce l'hanno in
tanti io lo so perché è un problema che
hanno un sacco di persone e sono andati
nei centri giusti e magari ce l'hanno
fatta è questo il modo vedrete che la
diffidenza si trasformerà in fiducia e
quella persona avrà voglia e bisogno di
parlare con voi
terza reazione allo sgomento
questo mi capita soprattutto quando
parla alle mie coppe e comunicò il fatto
che non potranno concepire con i loro
gameti perché purtroppo non ci sono più
o sono malati e dovranno ricorrere a una
donatrice di ovociti se il problema e
femminile ad un donatore di seme se il
problema è maschile quindi ad una terza
persona
allora vedo che loro non guardano più mi
guardano dietro ma dietro non c'è niente
loro sapete dove guardano nella loro
mente guardano il rincorrersi di idea di
tradimento perché ci sarà una terza
persona fra loro di impotenza di
fallimento di inadeguatezza e voi dovete
aspettare aspettare di recuperare il
loro sguardo
e di dire guarda che questa che si
chiama fecondazione eterologa
non è un ripiego non devi piangere è
un'opportunità
è una chance prima non esisteva adesso
la scienza e la medicina ci ha concesso
di poter ricorrere a questo
ma scusa se tu fossi in lista per un
trapianto di organo e finalmente
arrivasse l'organo tu che cosa
sentiresti tristezza sconfitta no
sentiresti una gran vittoria e voglia di
vivere questo devi sentire e se non sei
un medico fargli vedere che il problema
lo conosce perché lo conosci perché
tanta gente ricorso a questo anche
personaggi famosi che non si sono
vergognati di dirlo a tutti a
comunicarlo nei social
guardate non c'è nulla di più
rassicurante della consapevolezza di non
essere soli
e allora fate vedere a questa gente che
non sono soli sono in tanti e tanti
hanno raggiunto le stelle il loro
desiderio
consigliate un bel libro ce n'è uno
molto bello si chiama una delle tante di
loredana vanini consigliate una pagina
sui social diario di una vita sincero lo
ga con delle storie commoventi e alcune
che ti fanno venire la pelle d'oca
consigliate un bel podcast ce n'è uno
molto bello di alison porto molto
adeguato
fate capire che questa cosa esiste da
sempre consigliato una mostra la queste
frida kahlo frida kahlo combattuta tutta
la sua vita con infertilità perché ho
avuto un incidente e questo quadro che
si chiama il letto volante rappresenta
lei l'ha scritto proprio nel momento del
pitturato nel momento del suo secondo
aborto e guardate come rosso come lo
dipinge un letto dove lei sta purtroppo
abortendo sola nel nulla lei così si
sentiva sola nel nulla e queste persone
dovete farvi capire che non sono solo
nel nulla incoraggiateli tipe di provate
c è ma se poi non ci riesco è ho capito
ma se poi ci riesci fate la domanda
giusta
la domanda giusta non è perché non avete
figli la domanda è non avete figli per
scelta o perché non vi vengono quando
non sai costretto a rispondermi ma tu
sappi che se vuoi io sono qui che ti
ascolto
ed ora vi faccio fare un altro piccolo
viaggio indietro nel tempo se volete
chiudete gli occhi e pensate a quando
avete imparato ad andare in bicicletta
quella sensazione di aver trovato
finalmente l'equilibrio e l'aria nel
viso e nei capelli è una sensazione così
nuova non avete mai provato nulla del
genere e non la conoscevate e adesso
pensate a una persona che amate
se ne avete dei figli se non ne avete a
un compagno una compagna che avete amato
tanto
quell'amore come la conoscenza per la
bicicletta che non ci poteva essere
l'amore non lo potevi conoscere è nato
quando hai stretto per la prima volta il
bambino al coperto è nato quando hai
visto per la prima volta quel tuo
compagno e chi batteva il cuore
eppure io ancora oggi non riesco a
spiegarmi come queste persone che
intraprendono questi percorsi così
difficili sappiano cosa vuol dire
l'amore per un figlio senza averlo mai
conosciuto
questi secondo me hanno veramente una
vision of super
grazie